okay yeah well the end of this episode
am i right all right so we have a new
episode of one division episode
six time is flying and this is a spoiler
warning for episode six of wanda vision
stick around if you've seen it stick
around if you don't care but if you
don't want spoilers now's your time to
bounce so okay so as
the one division show the show within
the show the hex as they call it's been
going through the decades of sitcoms
i thought chronologically this would be
when the 90s were
but this is more of a 2000 show it's
like the 90s got forgotten though last
week it was on the fringe it was like is
it late
80s or early 90s maybe they were just
doing both with it but judging by
quicksilver's puka shell necklace and no
laugh track
early to mid 2000 regardless i thought
the dynamic was great because
quicksilver's like the cool uncle and
let's face it we all like to be the cool
uncle
it's just a fun job it's a fun it's a
fun life but there was a thought that
quicksilver wasn't really quicksilver
he seems to be quicksilver we also got
glimpse of zombie quicksilver with
bullet holes in him
so apparently i thought that would have
been kind of cool if when she saw him
with the bullet holes he was all like
zombie dead if it was aaron taylor
johnson but
it wasn't though there was a kick-ass
reference when he was like kick ass and
she was like kick
ass i was like wait is that i mean i
might be seeing
something that's not there i don't know
in a world where if you're looking for
references you're gonna see references
even if they weren't
meant to be references but she did say
kick ass
and the person who plays her brother not
in this reality another reality
was kick-ass sounds less and less like a
reference as i'm saying it
so i'll just say coincidence i'm not
going to use my leap card yet i have
some leaps to come later
when i start talking about my theories
about agnes and i'm not going to say
much about the twins
either cause i just i don't know much
about them from the comic books i'm not
gonna front i'm not gonna google and be
like okay
now i'm up to date and i'm gonna talk on
a video like i've known for years
i don't but it being halloween vision's
on the neighborhood watch
which he starts getting into pockets of
this town where people are just kind of
frozen or they're just doing the same
thing over and over again like that lady
and that husband just doing this and you
see a tear come out of her eye
which that always freaks me out it takes
me back to star trek the next generation
best of both worlds part two where
liquidus of borg
jean-luc picard he's on this slab he's
on this table and the borg are working
on him
and it shows his eye and the tears
coming out of his eye and you're like oh
my gosh he's conscious the fact that you
can be locks
in your head and you have no control
there was actually a side story for a
second there was a spider-man novel i
had that was a bunch of short stories of
spider-man
and one of them was dr connors he was
like okay i can get the lizard under
control i can suppress him
but it didn't suppress the lizard it
made him turn into the lizard and it
didn't suppress his consciousness so
he was conscious in the lizard's body
watching him
about to kill his own family it freaked
me out and vision just has enough of it
he's like i'm gonna go outside this
barrier and i'm just gonna see what's
out there the whole time i'm like dude a
hole's gonna appear in your head you're
gonna be like
you're just gonna die don't do that but
he does he starts getting out
out of the barrier and he can't it's
like pulling him back in piece by piece
point is and this is where
this episode actually it shows that
wanda does have a lot of control of this
reality
more than i think a lot of us thought
she freezes everybody
expands the reality expands the bubble
reality the one division reality the hex
so it swallows up vision and saves his
life essentially recaptures him but also
saves his life
also gobbled up a lot of other people
kat dennings is now
in that reality too a bunch of soldiers
a bunch of their army gear
or sword gear and yet like internet is
totally right about that as much as the
show
is telling us oh wanda's behind it all
she doesn't know how it started which
implies something else is at work
something we haven't
seen she talks with quicksilver and here
and quicksilver is like how are you
doing this
let's be real let's just let's talk and
she's like
i don't know i just i just am i guess i
don't know how it started a lot of
theories about agnes whether or not
she's mephisto maybe mephisto is a whole
part of it but even agnes was in her car
and she was just
in her car and vision touched her head
and she was like oh my gosh your vision
you're an avenger he snapped her out of
it like vision did that other dude last
week and although that dude did say oh
we gotta stop her she's doing this she's
hurting us it was pretty vague i totally
agree
but it looks like wanda i don't know who
the other she would be
though there is something peculiar about
agnes if i'm ever right in my theories i
count myself
lucky i'm not even counting on that if
for nothing else my theories
they're imaginative not always right but
man they're fun i mean i'll put some of
it on some of you folks my comment
section you brought this to my attention
actually you led me to this point
bringing up the fact that you know when
they were casting everybody in that
first episode that was outside
the one division bubble and we were
seeing sword actually
come to grips with okay who are these
people well let's find out who they are
they totally breezed right over agnes
why would they do that unless her name
is a familiar name or because they don't
know who she is because she's not
strictly speaking from their world from
the world of the mcu so it's possible
she's from another world in the
multiverse which kind of makes sense
because feige said one division was
going to lead into doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
multiverse being an operative word there
i think she's liv octavius from under
the spider verse granted large part of
that does come from the fact that
katherine han who plays
agnes played live octavius from into the
spider-verse that's not enough
you know it's not like captain america
there was ever the shot
that captain america is going to be like
flame on and combust into flame and oh
he's the human torch after all chris
evans played both but there are two
separate characters i totally get it
granted we're dealing with sony property
and mcu property
those lines have kind of blurred since
spider-man has come to the mcu
granted it's not a spider-man from the
into the spider-verse story and with
word that alfred molina is going to be
doc
ock and spider-man 3. the line between
what is the mcu and what is the
spider-man universe is just getting
fuzzier also and into the spider-verse
we'll spoil this through into the
spider-verse at this point feel like i'm
a little late giving you that warning at
the end of into the spider-verse when
the super collider that actually does
breach dimensions in reality is going
off
she gets smacked by a semi we don't see
what happened to her and what's the rule
the rule is
unless you see the body they're not dead
and i know deleted scenes aren't
strictly speaking canon because they
technically didn't happen but there is a
deleted scene where liv octavius
literally jumps into the super collider
multiverse breach
couple things that work against this
theory is when vision touched her head
and snapped her out of it she knew who
vision was she knew who the avengers
were
and that vision was dead assuming that
she might be from a world that didn't
have
any avengers or a vision peculiar that
she knew that then again if there's a
time gap between when she got here
and when this happens she could have
learned that also her atoms don't look
like they're
trying to come apart as happened in into
the spider verse so there is that could
be that wanda's fake world the hex is
keeping that from happening but if the
multiverse of madness deals with other
characters coming into other worlds
are they all gonna have to experience
that so in a world where we're seeing
more spider-man crossover and
liv octavius was in into the
spider-verse
which dealt with the multiverse that's
where my brain's going mostly yeah
because
catherine han but also to be fair live
octavius doc
ock was pretty awesome and come on if
alfred molina's doc ock is going to be
in spider-man 3 you know you want to see
those two team up
they'll be like the lutes twins of
cyborg octopus people or she's joe blow
nobody
or she's mephisto so yeah this week in
one division solid episode left off on a
holy [ __ ] kind of moment and i think a
lot of people
outside that bubble reality are gonna
start freaking out because they're gonna
be like wait
she can expand the world so where does
that end yeah action provokes reaction
and the reaction from this is not going
to be pretty people outside that reality
are going to get pretty scared
we will see what next week brings but
before we go
bonsai i think the sponsor of this video
this video is brought to you by raycon
raycon earbuds are the slick stylish
true wireless earbuds coming in at about
half the price of the competition and
they remain my forever workout earbuds
near and dear to the heart but also
great for audiobooks and those classic
reasons like
listening to music because they offer
six hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass and a more compact
design that gives you a nice noise
isolating fit they come in a range of
fun colors and patterns they come in a
variety of fit options no dangling wires
or stems they're discreet
and sexy i mean the hair is helping yeah
but
you know they'd be discreet without the
hair perfect for those moments you want
people to think you're listening
but you're just not so click the link
below or go to byracon.com
john's to get 15 off your order and
thank you once again to raycon for
sponsoring this video they're no
stranger to my channel so i appreciate
the continued support
all right so one division episode six
have you seen it what are your theories
about agnes about all of it regardless
if it's agnes or not
something happened that sparked this
into happening something happened that
made the bubble reality
that wanda's just unaware of what do you
think it is whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you